good evening everyone and welcome to the
south
eastern area planning committee meeting
on wednesday the 23rd of june 2021
my name is councillor vanessa bell and i
am the chairman of this committee
before we commence can you hear me
everyone hear me okay
[Music]
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i our school present to
work to the protocols agreed at council
on 29th of april 2021 in the interest of
member and officer safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak you might have to wave
at me quite
significantly because the visuals aren't
so great in here
and i will then invite you to speak at
the appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask put your visor on and speak clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
please ensure your microphones remain
off when not speaking
apologies for absent sperner thank you
chairman we've received apologies from
councillors boyce
and duik thank you thank you
item three minutes 26th of may 2021
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 26th of may 2021
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true and accurate record councillor
channel
which i had given by email was not
recording
i don't understand it was said on the
change on that night
however i think as a matter of fact it
does need to be reflected in the list
that i did with those apologies thank
you
thank you councillor channel if we can
amend judy noted
thank you very much um any other
points on the minutes no
can we do i have a second or i propose
that we uh
so move thank you agree by sense members
with the amendment agreed lovely
thank you written for
declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
members councillor stamp uh thank you
madam chair just to disclose i'm a
member of essex county council
and they are consulted in some of the
applications but there's no pecuniary
interest at all thank you thanks
item five twenty zero zero one zero
two slash res glebe meadow
southminster essex we moved to gender
item 5
pat found on pages 11-32 so
i can hand over to mrs staplehurst
please to present the report thank you
first of all there is a verbal update
for this application
um uh just some clarification the four
affordable dwellings
will be two bedroom dwellings not three
as referred to in the report
and condition two has also been updated
as it referred to
some plans which have since been
superseded
this application is a reserve matters
application for 13 dwellings
eight four bedroom market dwellings one
five bedroom market dwelling
and four two bedroom affordable
dwellings
the outline permission was allowed on
appeal in 2016
and approved permission for 13 dwellings
on the site
and the access taken from vicarage court
to the west
the principle of constructing
residential dwellings at the site has
therefore been established
this application seeks to approve the
matters of scale appearance
landscaping and layouts
this is the location plan with the site
outlined in red
for context you can see the southminster
train station on the eastern side
and the high street is in the north
western corner
this is the proposed development layout
the access which was approved at outline
stage
is taken from vicarage court to the west
the market dwellings are located in a
linear formation
central to the site and the affordable
dwellings are located within the north
eastern corner each of the market
dwellings has a detached garage and
driveway
and the affordable dwellings have their
parking on the driveways to the front
and side
the south eastern part of the site
consists of public open space
with an attenuation basin in the corner
additional planting is proposed around
the boundaries and within the sites
with much of the site remaining soft
landscaped
these are the plans of house type b1
which is on plots
one four and six
house type c one on plots three and five
d1 on plot two seven and thirteen
e1 on plot 8 which is the 5 bedroom
dwelling
and the affordable dwellings on plot 9
and 10
and the affordable dwellings on plots 11
and 12. and these are the detached
garage plans for the market dwellings
this is the street scene plan with view
a showing the view
facing west towards the market dwellings
which are central to the site
and view b showing the view facing south
towards two of the market dwellings and
two of the affordable dwellings
these photos show the site um the view
facing the access taken from vicarage
court
facing the site and the view of the site
again from the entrance
at vicarage court
and some photos showing the view east
from the north boundary
the view west from the east boundary
and the view along the eastern boundary
adjacent to the king george playing
field
up to the east and a view within the
site
it's considered that the details of
layout scale appearance and landscaping
are acceptable and there would be no
harm to the character of the area
the affordable housing and landscaping
proposed is compliant with the
obligations set out
in the section 106 agreement from the
outline permission
it's also considered that the proposed
development would represent sufficiently
high quality development in terms of
appearance and landscaping and would
provide a good level of amenity space
and parking provision and it's therefore
recommended for approval
thank you chairman thank you mr
staplehurst um
do any other officers want to speak
before i go to
members no members then i believe
over to you councillor helm thank you
madam chairman
um i noticed this has been called in by
councillor
strangely but yet he's not allowed to be
here not allowed to speak and it's his
ward
don't you think that's a bit ridiculous
he was andreas says the chair when you
were when he was there
you may think so councillor hell but i
couldn't possibly comment
okay so you can't answer thank you very
much councillor
who was also a southminster uh awards
member i believe
yes the only one uh at the moment
could you tell me what the southern
parish council's views are
oh miss staplehurst can you off the top
of your head
i think it said that there wasn't a
balance but i can't remember
i don't think they did no response i
thought so yeah
yeah okay thank you any other
councillor passenger thank you
could we go back to the um the slide
with the actual
um planting and all the the site itself
so is solely affordable housing
is all just in one area is that correct
from what i can see is that
and and their immunity space is really
small
isn't it compared to everybody else's it
just seems you know there seems a lot of
greenery elsewhere and that seems to be
shoved off in the corner somehow
and i just wonder you know is that a
good idea to have the affordable housing
sort of
compartmented over on one side and out
the way sort of tucked away as it were
and
everybody else kind of you know
in a different sort of aspect but also
notice that they don't have any garages
either do they
so that their parking again is just on
the drive
i don't know i mean is is that really
something that we're sort of
you know thinking is good planning when
we're looking at this
at this mr lee i know i've said would
you like
we're having some technical issues i pay
a counselor china's mike was also being
a bit problematic
i don't know
um it's an interesting question that
cat's bathroom is raised and now policy
does acknowledge that we don't want to
hold all the affordable housing units
together
wholeheartedly we haven't got policy
that would actually highlight that
one of the other things isn't something
that we've had problems with
historically
on some of the larger sites is that rich
providers
only want accommodation of a certain
scale they actually do not want
properties that are above a certain
scale so there's a value to it that
they won't be able to get hundreds like
in front of us and things so
we do have to make an balanced decision
about actually
what the rich providers want what will
actually be delivered supported by
housing alongside
competing with what the market wants and
you know there is
a difference sometimes actually to be
honest um
thank you miss lee uh council messenger
again
um i do yeah i appreciate all of that it
just
seems to me that
that the four rather than sort of
incorporating as
as we've just said really rather
incorporating the social the affordable
housing
um it seems to be you know it's it's on
a plot where you could actually put
one other house they seem to have
squeezed four in there and i think is is
that just to
you know circumnavigate the quota and
and get permission in some way it just
it just
looks poor to me really that you know
there are there are some families that
are going to be
squeezed into a corner and i don't know
what their
their aspect is what they're overlooking
i can't really make it out but um
i don't know it it just
feels to me a bit of a you know square
square peg in a round hole type
situation
and it looks like we've we've squeezed
them in sorry i'll let mr lee come back
i'm wondering whether it's important
here to make the um
distinction between affordable housing
and social housing
because this is affordable housing which
is
a very different yeah i apologize
chairman that was my mistake i didn't
mean
no worries counselor so if i can go to
mr lee to respond then cancel the
schemes then cancer step
of the points that um is raising is
the fact that there are affordable
housing properties
that it's actually considered before the
properties don't reflect the rest of the
site
here in congress with that and actually
to help
you know i think you know you're almost
misdirecting yourself i actually
highlight the fact that they are
affordable members don't think that the
urban grain has been considered
having a large block of a certain scale
certain
old development relating poorly to
another partner is one thing that
different highlight that they are the
affordable housing is because there is
no policy sound that they
or there is but not the scheme of this
scale where they would have to be more
inclined
more together don't worry deciding
yourself but there's my advice but yeah
thank you thank you um councillor skins
uh yes i i take on board uh comments
from uh councillor bassinger and there
was also
i wouldn't i wasn't quite sure of the
difference in materials between the
affording
affordable houses they looked different
their cladding was different can you
clarify
what they're actually made of the
affordable dwellings
through you chairman um they are
different materials
um i don't have a plan which shows
specifically um the specific materials
that they are
um but in the assessment of the report
and we did consider that
they used a mix of materials that are
also used um
within the market dwellings as well um
so yeah i think the plans don't
quite do it justice um obviously what we
want to
we would want to avoid a sort of sense
of ghettoization you know this is a
where the people who can't afford those
houses live
but having said that of course uh that
is the fact of reality i mean
some houses are more expensive than
others and i've
lived on a state where there were bigger
houses and smaller houses and it
wasn't the end of the world uh but uh i
do take uh
councillor bassinger's point uh and we
don't want to find ourselves in a
position where
houses uh just look worse because they
are more affordable they have
part of the whole point of having
affordable dwellings is having
affordable
good dwellings of a high standard thank
you
i'll go to council stand then councillor
hall please
counsel
i just want to echo exactly what some
cancer passengers
have said we we i thought originally we
weren't supposed to
alienate affordable it's supposed to be
integrated i think all the
surveys and everything that's carried
out to do with the ldp originally
anybody spoke to the police and it is
important that they
integrated to me cancer passenger is
absolutely right
they're stuck out on a sore thumbs with
what we say it looks like a sore thumb
it's not integrated i actually don't
like
don't like it and i actually thank mr
lee for the comments he made
uh earlier and i think it is it is
doesn't look it doesn't fit part it's
not integrated they could quite easily
be put
in the middle and if you put housing
that segregates because to me it does
look like it's segregation slightly
um you you can not saying you will
you can then later on get all sorts of
issues and difficulties
it's a proven fact when we looked at the
ndp and when we were doing ours for
burnham we did a lot of research on it
and it's really important people feel
part of that
i know it's linear but part of that
community that little community and that
little cul-de-sac they feel part of it
not stuck out on a whim um i'm sorry i
haven't come up with the policies it's
in breach of i don't know if it's in d1
but i actually don't like it and i i
really feel it should be part of that
linear decision linear
development proposal thank you madam
chair
thank you council stamp council hull
please
no i appreciate that unfortunately
however
the principle of 13 houses on this site
has already been agreed so
there will be 13 houses on this site
it's this is just the reserve matter the
design and layout so
unfortunately it's too late for that
argument councillor hal but thank you
councillor bill thank you um just to
confirm
that the drawing that's up there at the
moment
i think you'll find on the right hand
side it's
the schools that's part of the school
synthetic
for you chairman and the site is called
glee meadow yes
and to the right as we look up
do you mean this area and there yes all
across the end
um i don't know if that's part of the
school and that's that's part of
king george playing field i'm just there
i think
the school might be to the north
stations yeah this um
he's actually on school land or behind
that fence on the right-hand side of the
hedge
he's at southwestern school right okay
um
so isn't that cancer
the bigger block plan which might be
worth looking at which shows
the primary school is sort of right at
the very top
and uh to the right is some south midst
community hall and that's the sort of
collection of buildings they have down
there if you're going to go
uh and take some kids down to play
soccer on the on the
uh football what am i saying uh king
george the
fifth memorial field so i think the
school's north of it
the site isn't it i i i tracked that
statement now i've seen that plan
yes the school is to the north
um cancer stuff was there a proposal
then from you earlier madam chair no
because i don't know what policy it's in
breach of to be fair and i can't put
something if it's not going to stand up
because mr lee will tell me off
mr lee is smiling um
about the affordable housing is to the
side on its own
our policy allows for that up to a
certain figure
so that on its own wouldn't be a safe
direction of travel for reason
i said if members are you know members
just concerned that actually there was
a number of small properties to the side
that don't relate to the rest of the
site
that's different matter but the fact
that it is
affordable housing shouldn't be what
means that our policy allows that up to
a figure
13 which more than we've got
what normally happens i'm trying to
think of all the new estates that we've
got all this development we've now got
around us and i know when i walk across
the ones opposite from me
you have a mixture of two bedrooms
four bedrooms fiber and they look
absolutely fine because they're part of
the development and that you they don't
look out of place
whereas i do feel the picture's gone
again so i do apologize
i feel it looks as though it is stuck
out on a limb and it doesn't look as
though it's part of
the actual proposal or the development
so
that is my concern i mean what is it the
street scene i don't know what policy i
could
and if you're just saying that use all
happen to be small properties that don't
relate to the rest of it
that's one thing i'm saying so you can't
go these are
um affordable housing units and they're
not relating to because our policy
actually allows that to a certain extent
you're looking i think it's impossible
layout very similar to this um
that's a different issue as you always
say that was that was totally different
you can't then throw that back at us now
mr lee
when you say that was the total that
they didn't even look at reserve matters
i'm just giving a lot of members
i'm just trying to give you some
background information that wasn't
similar to the indicative layout that
was submitted
um but it said you know if members don't
consider that the earthquake you know
doesn't like it it's not created for
them or things like that if members have
that that we can that's what we're just
trying to
inform that but i would not encourage
do you think there is a a possibility
that it it could i don't know if you
would could defer it
to then go back to the developer
sometimes if the
if the members see fit that there is an
issue to go back to see if there is a
discussion to have have with the
developer to to
integrate it more do you think that
there might be a possibility to do that
so that wouldn't be my advice to members
no okay
councillor passenger then councillor
channel please thank you madam chair
the only thing i would like to say as
well is that um council schemes
has established that um the affordable
dwellings
are actually made of different material
and i think
another consideration would help um to
have them with the same material or at
least looking
similar to the houses that
are not affordable but as as a design
in itself to me it sticks out like a
sore thumb
that there's been squeezed in the corner
for
smaller dwellings which i don't think
really
is integrated at all and i just feel
that
those that lived there would feel very
much outside
of that community thank you thank you
councillor shanna
i'll have to speak loudly my mic's not
working can you hear me
yes um what i would say is that looking
at the report
and about the acceptability of their
thirteen things which has been
established to outline stage obviously
an appeal by the inspector
the report did make reference to the
layout that's now been coming before us
under the reserve matters
is essentially largely that which i
believe is that outline stage
indicative were there any particular
changes
i mean is it wholly the same or
different what i would say is
in my view bearing in mind the entrance
of that road
is referred to in the report in mayland
i'm aware
of when uh development's been put
forward
there have been refusals largely because
of disturbance
of the number of properties that are
going to access the road affecting
actually the residential developments
already there and i haven't noticed
that's been made in the report but there
will be extra noise and lights
cars going up and down with the office
of bills that's um
if you like uh not enough in the harm
degree to obviously
uh feel this should not be approved so
could i just have some comments
on that regarding this mirroring exactly
indicative layout that the inspector saw
when he announced that outline approval
under appeal thank you thank you
so much that's through you chairman um
it is a similar layout to the outline
permission and but without
having a look at those plans and
comparing the two
i can't confirm it is exactly the same
in relation to the noise and disturbance
um as has been said the principle of
erecting 13 dwellings on the site has
already been established
um so we can't sort of object to that
um at this stage thank you thank you can
you mr lee can you clarify whether the
entrance was
the same on the initial
that 13 houses on this site the access
con there is acceptable
and the principle of noise and
disturbance has been considered at that
time
thank you does that answer your question
councillor
thank you thank you councillor passenger
again i know we're not really supposed
to be discussing the access but the
actual access to the site
um is through a sort of a larger
community
and the roads are absolutely minuscule
that lead
the one the one road that leads to that
and should anyone be parking outside
their house
there is no way anything larger than a
small car would get to that site so i
find it really
hard to believe that the officers have
just approved the access
and the accessibility to that site and
actually deem it possible to build
13 or 14 houses or how many are 13
using you know cranes lorries god knows
what
through that that other community that
other sort of the wider community is
there's just
tiny roads and a school but um as you
say we we can't discuss that now so
it appears that the planning inspector
thought that it was okay
councillor passenger unfortunately
that's um councillor bill was that a
paddle in the air
yes it is yes
it's um the roadways they are accredited
to a certain standard which has been
accepted by
council that's the road that's coming in
from north
what is that blue line by the way that's
a bit confusing from here
is the blue line are you chairman i
think it's part of the visibility
display
i think it's part of the visibility
display
that you see we've okay the arrow going
over it's got horrible housing
and open space that is the boundary with
again georgia victor moore appealed
there is a pencil has been offensive for
many many years
what they doing brought up during the
discussions
what are they doing about consolidating
that and make certain
people can't get from there
so you chairman they have proposed
boundary treatments
i'd have to it does say in the report
i'd have to double check
um what boundary treatments they're
proposing but the whole site will be
bounded
by
about the fencing we've got to be sort
of reinforced
for the nature of the usage of the king
george b
okay i'll come back to you about looking
at the boundary
you councilman um members
if we don't have an alternative proposal
then
um i would propose that we accept the
officer recommendation do we have an
alternative proposal
or are you seconding that recommendation
thank you
councillor hell so all those in
favor take a vote either
show of hands show of paddles waving
around things
those in favor
one two three four is that an up or down
paddle it's an abstain kind of paddle
so we've got four i make it four
and all those against members
i've got one there
and abstentions
that's three so that is
passed that's it that's carried members
so that is approved
thank you so moving on to item
six twenty slash zero one
three four four slash full density
project trust
knightswood center steeple road
southminster
so this is a gender item six on pages 33
to 62.
so i don't have ms matthew's son
oh she is coming good good otherwise it
would have been
you in the hot seat so
um
i believe i know one of the trustees and
i believe that a fellow
trustee with me on another body that i
sit on
so i don't think
and councillor hall the same as well
thank you members so if i could
hand over to you miss matthews please
thank you just start the presentation
are you a bit challenged by the screens
counselor channel are you getting the
glare
absolutely
i'm not trying to make a break for it
halfway through
yes by all means okay
um thank you chairman good evening
members so this is a
an application at um the knightswood
center steeple road southminster
it's for the conversion of two of the
existing buildings
into 11 flats and two maisonettes and
the construction of two bungalows
to the rear so the application site um
is as you can see is there it's on the
eastern side of steeple road
to the s to the north and east open
countryside and to the west on the other
side of the road
is squid's care home to the south is the
care home which this site used to form
part of
so that's the location plan and um
the buildings that to be converted are
this this building here
and that building there
and so these two large buildings as i
said previously used the park the
adjacent care home
they're towards the front of the site
and then to the rear there's some timber
some single-story buildings which would
be demolished as part of the proposal
so that's a larger version of the
existing block plan
and as you can see that the building is
actually physically connected at the
moment
to or attached to the um care home here
so part of the proposal will be to
remove that physical link
which you'll be able to see on this
slide here so they'll create a
um access road access way um along this
southern boundary of the site
so this is one of the buildings here
that will be converted into 11 flats
and then this building here will be
converted into two
they're called masonettes but they're
just two dwellings really
um and then at the back you've got three
um
bungalows one single one detached and a
pair of semi-detached
and then the other building is this one
along here which would be
a cycle store and refuse door
the existing access is sort of they've
got an in and out access at the moment
so
one of the accesses will be closed and
they would just be using
the one um the one the other one that
will be manning and you've got parking
areas at the front and also in the
middle
and there's an area of communal um
me space proposed at the front of the
site here
that's okay the external media space
will consist of a mixture of terraces
and balconies gardens and communal
and a communal area as i've mentioned
and the existing reflects
as there would also be closed um
right so these are the buildings that
would be demolished to the rear
of the um site
and these are the proposed elevations of
this is the main building so this would
be the 11 flats
there's fairly limited changes to the
existing buildings there's some material
some and weatherboarding being added and
balcony be added
um and the fenestration pattern has been
tweaked but essentially it's the same
same building
and these are the floor plans so you've
got this first floor and there's a small
and second floor within the roof space
and then the ground floor and
with it and the little terrace being
them proposed
for one of the flats there so these are
the masonettes
um so you've got um two two-bedroomed
properties there
again the building is largely as it is
there are some fenestration changes
and obviously reconfigured internal
layout
um and these are the bungalows to the
rear you've got the detached one
and the semi-pair assembly attached
they're
you know got modern design and mono
pictures
but that does does help reduce the
height
of the buildings and compared to a pitch
roof
um elevations of the cycle and bin store
that i mentioned earlier
they've got some street elevations um
the top one being a long steeple road so
you've got the development here and then
this is
the care home um to the south and then
you've got an east west
um sort of cross section through the
site um with the main building here and
then the masonettes
set back slightly in the middle and then
you've got the
bungalows at the back the applicant has
provided some sketch scheme showing
before and after
and
quite similar and certainly in certain
terms of the size inside the building
um remains the same and then we've got
some photos
showing the um so this this one on the
right is
the entrance to the site one the one
that's going to be closed
and and then you've got other photos
showing the app buildings at the back
which will be demolished
and um and different views of the
existing buildings to be converted so
the development has been assessed as
being acceptable in principle
and overall specifically taking into
account the benefits
and its contribution towards the council
five-year la having the immense supply
at a time when the supply is
significantly below five years
um that would weigh um that would
outweigh the limited harm the
development caused in relation to
accessibility
in particular the provision of 16
presidential units a limited distance
from the settlement of south minster
would weigh significantly in favor of
the proposal and there would also be
economic
benefits generated and the other points
worth
mentioning is the proposed larger
conversion of existing buildings
and rather than new build and which were
used for a residential related use
um and there will also be a number of
buildings which will be demolished so
that to real the site development is not
anticipated cause
material harm to the current appearance
of the area the immunity
occupies enabling properties or nature
conservation
development has also been found to be
satisfactory in terms of the quality of
life for the occupiers of the units
and no objections are raised in relation
to flood risk and drainage
provision for adequate access and levels
of parking would be made
applicant has already made the necessary
financial contribution towards
rams and
officers consider that conditions could
add
adequately cover the issue of onsite
ecology
and the applicant has also agreed to
enter into a section 106 agreement
um to ensure that if they propose to in
larger site at any point in the future
um no necessary provision of affordable
housing would be made
so on that basis recommended that plan
permit is granted
subject to section 106 agreement and the
conditions are set out in your agenda
papers
thank you thank you ms matthews
um members as you know we have now
returned to in-person public
participation
however as chairman i've exercised my
discretion and agreed
due to mitigating circumstances to read
a submission
from an objector mr matthew newberry
mr newbury states this proposal is
situated in an unsustainable location
outside
the settlement boundary of south minster
it has been stated that southminster
school and gp surgery would be a
reasonable level of services and
facilities to meet the day-to-day needs
of future occupiers
the current strain on services and
facilities does not appear to have been
taken into consideration
and nor does the likely impact that this
proposal would have on them
there is no footwear leading from the
site to the village thus raising a
highway safety issue
and increasing the reliance on private
car use which will in turn result in
increased vehicular movements within the
village
it should be noted that there are
limited bus services using steeple road
it would be inappropriate to increase
the accommodation on the site with the
provision of three bungalows
additional accommodation would fall
outside of reusing existing buildings
and should weigh against the proposal
development in south minster is at odds
with local services
facilities and infrastruct
infrastructure making it an
unsustainable location for development
any other officers wish to comment
before i throw the debate open
okay members counselor bail please thank
you
um
there is a problem down there we've got
lots of people
across the world
within the united states
adjacent to that side thank you um ms
matthews
yeah through chairman there is actually
a bus stop right outside the site
um i can't remember exactly where it is
but there is one right outside the site
and in the agenda papers i have set out
the
um the best services that are provided
to that
to and from that bus stop thank you
thank you
well there there is a bus service and
for a rural area
it it it covered most of the day
and there was even a service on sundays
so it seemed to provide um
no if you take into account the rural
location site it did seem to provide an
option for people living on the site to
be able to use the bus rather than
having to get in their car
and so there were services um going from
memory now but
you could get to maldonado obviously get
into south minster and the railway
station and
down through to burnham um so it
it it did seem obviously could not
compare to an urban area but
um it did there was um an adequate level
of um
bus services for the site yeah i think
cats
the main service comes in
is nowhere
mr lay and then i will come to you
cancer skeinstein
access to public transport and
you know the technology that it won't be
as frequent
the bottom
are using in the scooters etc
so are they supposed to be driving on
the plane
do you change that the existing problem
you're talking about
yes it could be yes that's not an issue
this application
my understanding is highways have
approved this
or have not not approved they have not
not raised any concerns to this
application
what's happening now old people's
accommodation that's surrounding it
um if the committee asked if it's done
before
we have written to the highway but you
know we've
never
thank you thank you could we send you a
letter
um we can councillor beale could we do
that please
um committee
um do we wish to do that all those in
favor
to write a letter to highways outlining
our concerns
um yeah yeah can we agree that by scent
members
thank you thank you i'm going to go to
cancer skins then council channel please
yeah i don't know whether this is
possible but i'm looking at the
google map vision of it and the
advantage of that
is that it shows you just how rural this
particular place is there's um
as you go up steeple road you're you
there's this
this collection of houses some of the
photographs we've already seen which
have a very rural feel the new
development doesn't have a rural
feel and it just feels like we're
encroaching into the countryside more
and more with developments like this
i am concerned and i don't know whether
we have any
power over this it seems we don't but
but
i'm concerned about the amount of um
development happening
and no commensurate increase in
facilities the concern that the
villagers
and the people in the town of south
minster have about the fact that their
surgery is full and the usual things
that we hear in burnham and southmanster
so often but but particularly it's the
rural aspect aspect and as councilor
beal has been pointing out
the nature of steeper road the good news
about the google map is it does show
two um bus stops there my concern
my concern is the people who live in
these houses and these are not
the old older generation that uh
necessarily that are living by
i just think it's gonna it's just not
the right place for such a large
development
um and it's outside the settlement
boundary and it's pushing out into the
countryside
and i know we are under tremendous
pressure from central government to push
into the countryside
but where we can resist it we live in a
rural area and i feel that we are
compromising at every turn the rural
status of where we live until
it's just going to become easier and
easier to
put more and more development in until
eventually we become an urban area
i know that sounds extreme but it's how
it's beginning to feel and i'm
not alone in those feelings thank you
councillor skeins councillor channer
thank an element that really you
me and it has been mentioned in the
report and
i'm going to refer to the 106 heads of
terms i mean we're always told we
mustn't think about what might happen in
the future
uh you know we have to deal with
everything that's done
read in the report and there are
concerns um getting away
from it now about this site being
intentionally separated
from the another side and i was quite
surprised i will be frank to see the
heads of terms stating quite
specifically in my
opinion affordable housing shortfall to
be mitigated
through a joining site i felt that was
almost inciting
phase two this could be phase one and
i'm just concerned that in a way the
authority
is indicating perhaps the permission
could be forthcoming for something else
by the very words used an overage clause
in bullet point one
and bullet point two all will have in
shortfall
to be mitigated through the joining site
that to me is inciting another
application should this be approved
for a larger cell and that is something
that really concerns me
bearing in mind advice given to members
throughout the years i've been on this
council
thank you thank you i'm going to go to
you mr lee there
surprisingly
law is clear that if it can be perceived
an african has intentionally
split aside to sort of
gain some sort of uh benefit in relation
to affordable health
vision or visions generally
that joint side has to shoulder the bird
if there's an apparent
intentional approach so
irrespective of whether or not we had to
put that condition on if there was a
subsequent application that came forward
because at the time persian site is one
site that the package has put up for
everyone to be able to see
we would legally have a right to do that
the applicant is fully aware of the
point of law
and this debit sector is part of 2016
his clarity is even to protect us
it's not lpa or the council or
acknowledge or invite to the second
application
um to be honest you know bullet point
maybe it's not working perfectly but
it's um
which i'm quite happy i've had to get
myself personally quite late actually
one council channel really
isn't
[Laughter]
would tie into the adjoining peace land
which would mean
even if it was sold off in the future it
was there will still be financial
litigation towards the council so it's
it's a
racist approach and i hope that you know
if members wanted informative that went
on any approval that stated something on
the lines of you know
the uh requirement to escape through the
joining site if necessary does not
thank you before i go to council stamp
counselor channel does that allay your
concerns
at all no it doesn't
critical and that's what um this order
paper to me i don't know the wording
that would be applied on the flushing
out of that there'd have to be a
schedule obviously should everything be
the same
i think it is inciting further
development to come forward
and you know that concerns me about the
basis
of the application
thank you cat no thank you councillor
stamp please
thank you madam chair i'm looking at the
conclusion 3.2.2
and it says the development is not
anticipated to cause material harm to
the character or appearance of the area
humanity or occupiers for neighbouring
properties or nature conservation
i totally disagree with that i think
it's totally out of character
i think it is another another
development that is taking away
the character of what we need to be
preserving
for this district i'm not saying we
shouldn't have development and there but
they should be in a suitable place
i don't agree with the officers that
it's in a sustainable location
i myself have been to knightswood many a
time when i was the mayor of burnham to
support
events and things that go on there and
it is out in the sticks it's difficult
to find there is no footways and once i
take on board what mr lee
said to mr to counselor beal about is
there's an existing problem about
footpaths or whatever it may be is but
it's still going to be a problem if this
development
is actually approved so there is still
an issue
of actually putting the facilities the
footpath making it safe
to the residents who are going to be
living in this development if it is
approved madam chairman
i do not like it and i'm sorry madam
chair
but i won't be supporting it and i would
like to put a counter proposal
that we reject it for the reasons that
i've just said that i don't i think it
is against policies
i don't is it what is it mr lee policy
what i've just said
is that it is it is harmful mr lee
to the character and appearance of the
area i i think it is
um not sustainable i know you're going
to argue that there's a bus stop and
everything yes there are five buses i
think i read because i've read the
report
and and i think it is encroaching on the
countryside and i think it goes against
policy h4 i think that's my that's my
view other members may have a different
mod
madam chair they may support it they may
not but that is my view
i i do not will not support it madam
chairman
okay thank you do any other members wish
to speak or
the councillor how were you thank you
madam
i'm a chairman confused really because
normally when it's outside the village
boundary
narrow roads no pavements no street
lights
the officers recommend refusal yet here
we are recommending approval
that's a mile to walk to the bus to the
doctors
or the chemist or anything at least a
mile if not more
and the first bit of the road down to
the s benz is absolutely dangerous
you wouldn't want to walk along there
let alone cycle it's so dangerous
you can't even get two cars round the
bend one one is
adequate and if a lorry comes around
they're gonna help us all
yeah so although you say we've got uh
bus service fine we'll have to rely on
the car which are both
fuel guzzling emissions all that sort of
thing in the countryside which you don't
want
and we're struggling to get down to the
doctors which are
you probably won't get into either
because that's full up
you won't get the school because that's
full up where are we going why are we
recommending this
don't the officers now realize what's
going on
thank you for that thank you rather kurt
i apologize would you wish to come back
mr lee
objection to this whether or not you
agree with that evidence that there's
any harm in perspective matters such as
that
um this site is
at the moment could be doing a c2
unit for a care home uh without need to
plan commission
there could be more people living in
that property tomorrow than they're
where they're proposing to do during
this application and that is material
consideration
determination application you don't
necessarily agree with officers but it
is mature situation that
it is and can lawfully be used for
habitable accommodation
second is magic show you know there is
quite a lot of
built form already on this side and
obviously some needs to be removed and
that it has to be a balancing process
against the
application and you know this isn't a
virgin green
field we are significantly short in
relation to
housing units and government does
encourage reuse of
ground sites which this is and those
mature situations but wait heavily in
this paper and to pick up the
councillors
income from earlier um
more we have to make this difficult
decision
whether it's this application or another
one you know we will have to make
difficult decisions
and if if we struggle
more and more to deliver a five-year
amplifier
the quality of defendants we'll be able
to say no to
will get lower and that is the reality
of it um
once you know and so yeah
we are you know we are conscious of the
lack of bargaining it's a tilted
bouncing plate for them
this is a brownfield site it can be used
for residential accommodation
maybe not dwellings accommodation
tomorrow and all those things weigh
exceptionally heavily in favor of this
application
and that's why views of class counseling
well that's exactly why it's up for
approval
thank you thank you i'll go to cancer
skins then cancel us down
please wanted to come back with
something mr lee
will you give away thank you thank you
catherine i just wanted to come back
with the care home situation i totally
agree exactly what you said so
a care home care home can be built there
but i think you'll find
possibly that the strategy coming from
essex county council or central
government is that care homes are not
going to be so popular now
because they're looking at looking after
people within their home so i think
in future you're going to have less care
homes because of the change in
it is coming from central government mr
lee anyway i know it is
do you disagree with me because you're
looking at me
oh mr
and that will probably lead to a
reduction in demand for
yeah but what that'll mean is we have
vacant care homes
such as this and whether or not and
that's the direction of travel
you know at the moment is that where we
are right now
and that's the application in front of
us right now and it may well be
transparent
we have
but that's something for the future not
for this application at this moment
thank you thank you mr luke how's the
schemes
yes the future it's always so difficult
we're not meant to think about the
future and
less of course we have to think about
the future and i'm just looking at this
image here there's development 500
meters or so to the south
uh it's inevitably going to it seems
likely
it's going to connect up along the
steeper road which is inadequate
there's no provision to improve the
connections to the town and that's the
key thing for me
if it's going to be care home people
living there people are people who are
in care then one assumes there may be
carers and people to help them with the
transport but here
we have a situation where we have a thin
uh
a small road a steeple road and no other
way
uh in or out except by there and it just
seems
that that what is on that site already
is enough thank you very much and if
we're going to add more
which is out of character which is
entirely visually
out of character with the rural area of
the photographs that we were shown i
just don't think that's
good that's that's good i think it's bad
in fact and while i completely
appreciate
mr lee's concerns about the five-year
housing supply and i understand it
i just think that this particular
location is not the place to do it
yes we have to do this we have to bend
to the authorities
above us that tell us that we have to do
this but i just don't think we should be
doing it here that's my view thank you
thank you
okay so we have a proposal i believe
which was um
to go against the officer recommendation
so i take that one first i believe yes
so members the proposal is to go against
the
officer recommendation can we do that by
a cent or do we want to
could you cancel please
thank you madam chair thank you mr lee i
basically said
i believe it does cause material harm to
the character and appearance of the area
um and the occupiers of the neighbouring
properties what i said a few other
things as well i can't remember exactly
what the other ones were we should read
it down did you take minutes
hang on i've got i've got another one
because i've highlighted it somewhere
else go on burner you'll help me out
please
h4 yes please
of the site further on
like all those and then we've got this
just i mean we've got clear rural style
housing there
and then you go back together there's
just a massive contrast between the two
in my subjective point of view
so counselor stamp you said that it was
you'd felt it was harmful to the
character and appearance of the area
not in a sustainable location
encroaching on the countryside and
contrary to policy h4
yeah basically comprehensive council
staff
thank you thank you narrow narrow road
with no pavements and no street lights
it's exactly the same isn't it mr lee
yeah that's i was slightly confused
about that
phrase
this photo here on the right that's
that's that did look quite a small
building but in fact
in reality um
that is that building there and the view
that you just saw was just
the small front elevation it goes all
the way back here and that's also an
existing building
and so that's existing view from steeple
road looking
um from the north and this is proposed
so
that building is all still there in fact
it's going to be made slightly smaller
because they're going to take the link
off between that and the
care home and then this building here is
the same
it's the same size same height um the
only
um new build
is the um you know you can see it was
the
um cycle and refuse door which is this
um
little low profile building along the
the boundary
and the other element was the um
the single story bungalows at the back
so
all this here is already there
what like that like that yeah with
windows it just doesn't
how can it look so different from the
photograph and that
just doesn't make sense to me that that
looks like a pretty
standard modern development which
doesn't really fit in the countryside
you can find it in any city
and then we've got the one the
photographs that we actually see that
look like rural buildings in the
countryside
how has the architect or the developers
managed to do
something that looks so different and
that's what we've got to go with we've
got to go with what we can see we can't
go with
what we imagine councillor channel
well yes thank you um just going back to
mr lee
and saying about what's saying
um the report actually made it quite
clear that essex county council i
thought had tried to market this as a
care home
yes and then there was no doom was
actually marketed by lambert smith
hampton
from april 2018 as a care home as ecc
had no further use for the property but
whilst there was interest expressed no
financial offers were made by kevin
providers
so i'm not mr lee's saying but here we
have the fact
it was marketed so hence why officers
they feel that it's more acceptable how
residential um
on this site but i just made that point
thank you mr lee would you like to come
back and then cancel schedules
uh
but that doesn't take away the simple
fact that the fallback position is
if they decided to there could be the
people in there tomorrow and that is
that just before that position is a
mature situation international
application i'm just providing members
with
all of them saving
thank you councillor then councillor
passenger then councillor stamp place
up on the board it says proposed
elevations main block could we go back
to
existing elevations main block well
i didn't actually put them on because
they were um
so similar to what was there but well
that's that i mean
this is where we are we're at this
critical phase i think we do need to see
them if we can
because i can't remember i i i didn't
look at this but i can't remember them
being the same
and i just remember being shocked by
that but if they are the same then
my argument is not as strong as i
thought it was my understanding is that
they've stuck a rather unattractive
balcony type thing on and changed the
fenestration slightly
would that be about right that's nothing
thank you councillor passenger please
oh it's deciding whether it's going to
work or not it's flashing green at us
there we go that's working yeah i would
just you know like to backtrack really
and just say i agree
with everything pretty much that's been
said especially by a councillor stamp
um i think we're looking at a site which
really and truly
to me is totally unsustainable it's
outside of the uh
of the village of the um of the boundary
which has been established i don't know
how far away is from the main settlement
but it certainly isn't within walking
distance i believe
when we're looking at this how many
flats are there may ask please
is it eight there's 16 units
in total and three of those will be
bungalows
so um 13 13
13. so you know we're looking at 13
possibly you know each each of those
places would have to have a car
so i mean i i presume there is adequate
parking within that
term development
my understanding is it meets the parking
spg does it
through time and yes the um parking
provision is is the
um at least the minimum that we would
require to comply with the spd
but certainly you know to get apart from
this meager bus service to get to the
main settlement
each person would need to go by car so
that puts more pressure
i think also i think poor old south
mister has had enough pressure put on it
and this is just adding i think also
when you look at the design of this i
know we are looking at the same building
they're not knocking it down they're
going to
refurb the same building but i must
admit
the the the new aspect that we're
getting
looks far worse than the old one so
as far as design is concerned you know
i'd seem to see the old one there in the
old site
when i look at that i find that really
distressing that looks completely
out of character for a rural area
that to me is that's
box standard housing estate and i guess
that is the same building just with
i don't know windows put in it but it
certainly hasn't added
anything to uh to the design in fact i
think it's detracted so i would say
poor design is is possibly a feature
just
just one other thing there was there was
a mention of economic
um benefit exactly how is economic
benefit being brought
by this is it just number of people
microphone oh sorry thank you um
yeah you chairman that that's a i mean
it's a general comment
in terms of any resident development
that there will be jobs created
through the building the builders and
the
suppliers for for the project and
there is also the economic side of
things
in terms of additional customers
for any existing businesses in south
minster
and and any of those services and in
rural areas sometimes
it it can be quite advantageous to have
extra customers to make services more
viable than
there might be if they didn't have quite
so many people um
to serve so so it's not um it's
certainly not
one of the main arguments of um in terms
of
in support of the application but it is
a factor and it is something that the
government requires us to
take into account and if it went to
appeal that would be certainly something
that the inspector would
um refer to as part of their decision in
um
and say that there would be some
economic developments and benefits sorry
thank you cancer could i just quickly
come back on that sorry
i mean again i think when we're looking
at um the tilt system
which is is the way we are governing
things the balance system sorry
you know we're looking at normally the
sort of three or four elements and here
we've got sustainability which
i think is is completely it's not
sustainable
and economic and actually in itself it's
not really bringing
anything economically apart from maybe a
footfall or somebody going to the shop
and some short-term employment for
builders but in itself
economically it's not really adding
anything
to the to the area apart from very very
small so
if we're looking at the balance system i
would say the balance system is sort of
dictating that this should not be um
an approved site thank you cancer
schools
is that is it possible to bring up the
existing elevations not on the
presentation i believe
is that right i can't find it that's a
trouble no i've got them
on my my here my this but
did you want to come back whilst miss
matthews is looking okay
nick will you turn y'all sir okay um
thank you madam chair it says here
policy evil supports the change of use
of existing rural buildings to other
employment generation uses
the the conversion of the rural
buildings to the residential use would
therefore conflict with this policy
so and i'm trying to find everything i
know i haven't read everything
today and i do apologize madam chair but
you know it is in conflict with our
policies
so you know policy s8
of the ldp steers new development
towards existing urban areas
you know it it's not it's not a really
urban area to me it's a rural area
you know and you're going to urbanize it
by putting
13 flats there and three bungalows or 11
flats and three bungalows
you're creating as far as i'm concerned
or this council would create
why classes were urban sprawl and i
totally take on board what um councillor
bassinger said
yes you can turn around and say you're
bringing employment but it's not
you're actually going to be taken away
from other services that we're
struggling with
which every other members mentioned
which is schools
um doctors etc so that to me has got to
be balanced as well within the report
and yes i know the argument is and mr
lee's heard this to me and i shall say
it even with the next round of ldp
we have to balance school places we have
to balance
nhs services because that's what we're
elected to do to represent our
residents and we have to keep fighting
and i actually don't believe
as i said madam chair at the beginning
it is in the right place
yes please and then and then i would
like to go to the vote members please
yes we are mr lee but yes we are mr lee
but we're also elected
to take into consideration and and to be
um
well i've said it now i can't retract it
if i want if somebody wants to report me
for saying that then there's a process
for reporting me for saying that and i'm
happy to stand up and and say that mr
lee
but the thing is the thing is that yes
we are here
you know and i'm not a ward member
either i am the leader of the council
and i do not agree with this
application for the reasons i've said
and i will listen to what you say
but then you've also got to listen to
what we say
members i'm going to go to the vote now
um so we are taking the vote on
councillor stance proposal seconded by
cancer schemes
that we go against the offer officer's
recommendation and refuse
this development clarity
i think councillor helm raised that
point and i actually reiterated it
but i i raised the question of policy e4
supports the change and
i didn't get response to that
yeah bernice berner's taken some
comprehensive yeah
it's not a case of what others have said
and
policy d1 is designed so the position of
compatible sport in the air wouldn't
fall under d1
um you know as always advise members you
don't need to specifically reference
policies that's how we'll do support
members through
formation of the reasons for refusal but
if there are clear points we can
build
i believe bernie you read back see
earlier would you like to do that again
for us thank you
um so um cancer stamp
um made the following state of the
following reasons
that it was harmful to the character and
appearance of the
countryside not in a sustainable
location
encroaching on the countryside country
to policy
i think she said h4 at the time are
urban sprawl issues and
obviously and sorry impact on
infrastructure
thank you bernard does that give us
enough to work with uh mr lee
madam chair madam chair we can do an
amendment if members
surely we can do an amendment if members
feel as though there are
other um policy issues that came out
throughout the debate
we can do an amendment to my image
original one because lots of things
came up after i said my um
uh for me everybody's contributing to
this debate
so if uh councillor stamp has come up
with a list of reasons doesn't mean to
say that we ignore
councillor helm's reasons or council of
passenger seasons or
councillor schemes or cancer anybody i
am counselor
all the reasons are the reasons uh we
are not
uh experts in making those into the
reasons but we have to take them all to
look at
not just a council of stamps
you know you know if members said
something that was
a folly uh that had no plan
i wouldn't want to just because that was
part of the debate then that's a form of
reason for refusal so
obviously says this has a very big
debate carried a lot of various points
and i think officers just want some
clarity
on what they have and now you know we've
got
the first motion i've been together
would be an earthquake critical design
urbanization and about three different
points i'll bring that together in one
reason for a few what i recommend
i'll see this point about infrastructure
and then there was a sustainability
myself
workforce refusal from what
council stands for if members wish to
prepare another effort
that's within
my understanding from previous debates
mr lee is that less is
more in terms of objections so i would
be wary
of adding anything more on really if you
feel that that we have enough
acceptable um so you know it is up to
the members it's in their just gifts and
decisions
i would never encourage you just for the
sake of it or anything because
we know you can win an appeal and still
have possibilities against you because
of the fuse with flaws um but yeah
thank you do we wish members to add an
amendment to councillor stamps proposal
or are we happy to take it as it is
can i speak first please go ahead i'd
like to say uh
thank you for mr lee for his advice and
i will ask for advice on sustainability
do you feel the sustainability um or
lack of it on this application
would stand up so people would have to
go there for work businesses would
deliver people with their businesses
there i don't think you could stand up
and you see that's why it's a valid
point to everything everybody ever said
about the debate and we listen to the
officers with that guidance but if
anybody else has
i mean the sustainability for me was not
that there is
because there is a bus stop and we've
had this argument when councillor duik
councillor fluker and everybody used to
attend all the other meetings at
southeast
we had numerous debates on debate
sustainability
so i'm quite happy to remove the
sustainability and
put that amendment but if anybody else
has got another suggestion
on the amendment i do think we need to
say so now thank you madam
council um shannon understand regarding
sustainability there's the three main
strands as they're not
um social economic and environmental and
i've heard in the debate
uh from councillor schemes and other
people they're concerned about
where this exactly is um situated i
think it counts as a stamp
so i myself might have concerns if
that's the reason coming forward to
remove it in its entirety
because certainly officers always
consider the three personal points
of sustainability in their orders as
indeed the inspectors
so is that are we tracking that then
madam chairs
suggest that we leave sustainability in
mr lee
um
you know public service
i don't think that that would be a good
refusal that would
stand up because members have a concern
in relation to balance and
sustainability
and that all about that that could be
that sustainability
you know so we'll stick with with what
we have
so members all those in
favor of councillor stamps proposal of
refusing this against
officer recommendation please raise
hands paddles or anything else handy
that's one two three
and all those against
one two and
abstentions
that's three i'll make it
and actually i think it would be good if
we did
actually a
we're taking a recorded vote on
councillor stamps proposal to refuse the
officer's
recommendation of approval so we're
clear
thank you members i will call your names
in alphabetical order can you please
stay clearly
for against her abstain starting with
councillor bassinger
four
councillor beale
councillor bell epstein
cancer china
cancer hound against
councillor hall
councillor schemes full
thank you members that's four for the um
proposal to refuse the application two
against
and two abstentions
sorry three upset cancer channel yes
three abstentions
sorry it's with the apologies mixed in
yes
do you want me to repeat that that's
four for the refusal of the officer's
recommendation
two against and three abstentions
thank you so that is refused
contrary to officer recommendation i
believe we do have the reasons
thank you members sorry can i just
have those figures again one two
sorry there's just we have i think
that's correct
sorry it's councillor passenger for
councillor
chan channel is absent i think it's
three
yeah sorry it's just this confusion with
the
it's three and two three four
three abstentions it's three two three
it's
three four two against and three
abstentions apologies i put
one in cancer dueck's section
yeah apologies for that it's just the
and it's my accent of that i think
thank you so moving on to item seven on
the agenda
twenty one slash zero zero three zero
zero slash full rest of oil
in fanbridge road oakland essex
so this can be found on pages 63-76
and i'm going to hand over to miss
dungate please thank you miss matthews
flying into position it's done guys
thank you chairman planning permission
is sought for the construction of a new
four bedroom chalet bungalow at the
application site
which is located on the south side of
fanbridge road
a new front boundary wall and gate is
also proposed as well as external
alterations
to an existing shipping container and
shed at the site
this is the site location plan for the
application
the southern part of this section of the
road um is largely open and free from
built form
with a small cluster of dwellings
located southwest
of the application site down here
and two detached dwellings located east
of the application site over here
these are the existing and proposed
block plans
at present there are some existing
temporary structures within the site
such as a caravan
storage container and some small scale
buildings
including timber sheds the site is also
used for the storage of boats
the site has an established leisure use
for the stationing of a mobile home for
seasonal occupation
however there is no planning history to
suggest that the site has an authorized
use for permanent residential
accommodation
as the existing caravan is a temporary
mobile structure
the proposed dwelling cannot be assessed
as a replacement dwelling
in line with policy h4 of the the modern
ldp
and as such has been assessed as a new
house within the rural area for the
purposes of this application
these are the existing elevations
from the front and rear of the site
and these are the existing side
elevations
these are the proposed front and rear
elevations
and these are the side elevations
this is the proposed section showing
that the site drops down from north
to south
and these are the existing and proposed
street elevations
this is the proposed ground floor plan
for the application
which also shows the extent of the
parking area proposed at the front of
the building
as well as the access drive and front
wall
this is the proposed first wall pan
these are the outbuilding elevations
and this is the proposed front wall
elevations
these are photographs looking towards
the front of the site from fan bridge
road
and these are photographs looking east
and west along fanbridge road
as you can see from the photographs
there is heavy vegetation
along fanbridge road which makes a
positive contribution to the rural
character of the area
and these are just some more photographs
showing the existing temporary
structures within the site
which is largely open and free from
built form
um so in line with the assessment
carried out within the committee report
the principle of constructing a new
house in this location is not considered
to be acceptable
given that it would be located within
the rural area outside of the defined
settlement of orthorn
for the reasons explained in the
committee report the new house would be
disconnected
from the limited services and facilities
located in orthorn
by reason of its inaccessible location
and would provide
poor quality and limited access to
public transportation
resulting in an increased need of
private vehicle ownership
which would not amount to sustainable
development in this area
furthermore the proposed development due
to its design and layout would result in
substantial
urbanization of the site which would
result in significant
harm and detract from the character and
appearance of the countryside
it is therefore recommended that
planning permission is refused for the
proposed development
thank you chairman thank you very much
mr dungate would any other officer like
to
come in mr leno no members
over to you councillor bassinger
and then council chance thank you madam
chairman um
uh can i just say first of all that um
the applicant mr beanie has contacted me
and would like it to be noted that he
would have liked to have come and
spoke this evening but apparently he
registered too late
um and also allthorn parish council
would have also liked to come this
evening and make some representation
but unfortunately they're meeting
clashes and they would have been in
corinth so uh that they couldn't come
as well um i was i was the the
i i called this application in because i
was contacted
on the belief that uh the plot had
um lawful development and was in fact a
residential plot and i was just
i can see from the officer's report that
that's not the case but i'd just like
to clarify that that there is no
lawful development for residential on
this site
and also um the fact that there is a
mobile home on there and not a caravan
um that was also something that i was
told and that was also being used as
residential
so they're just a couple of points um
i'd like to clarify if that's
correct or not yep through youtube
um so in 1994 a lawful development
certificate was
um granted for seasonal occupation
of the site with a mobile home so that
doesn't equate to permanent residential
accommodation at the site
so i'm not sure about the the actual
details of
when they were to occupy the site
whether it was
from february to august or whatever but
it was only granted for seasonal
occupation a mobile home is essentially
a caravan
as per the caravan act because it is a
move a movable structure
that can be moved around the site um
so therefore as explained within
section 5.2 of the report it
doesn't amount to an existing dwelling
as per policy
h4 so yeah there isn't an established
permanent res residence at the site and
therefore if they are occupying the site
on a permanent
basis then actually that's unauthorized
thank you does that answer your question
it does could i just
clarify one other point which was made
to me
um and that's that um the applicant had
received a letter
in july 2019
um stating that he had residential
um permission or residential planning i
just wondered if there was any
any records of that at all
through you chairman i can see that a
pre-app
was submitted which i'm not sure is a
public document so i'm not sure i can
actually
disclose the details of that pre-app so
they haven't applied for
an official lawful development
certificate for
the existing use of the site as a
permanent residence
which they would need to demonstrate at
least four or ten years that it's been
used as a permanent residence which
there isn't planning history for so
therefore in the eyes of
the planning system there isn't an
established permanent residential use at
the site
since 1994. thank you thank you thank
you councillor chana i believe you wish
limited range of facilities and services
including a relatively small post office
door to
yes one card to these that's correct
um i'd like to say um i believe this has
got this absolutely spot on
um i'm very well aware i will declare an
interest i live in austin but not
particularly near to this site
whatsoever and
finally quite frightening when i didn't
see the plans because i looked at it
um where i was coming from meeting 19.7
which i mean we're talking about that's
what we're talking about the width of
this building proposal
i mean we're talking about thing they're
65 foot
by 49.5 feet
and the whole frontage would be
not landscapeable it's going to be sort
of concreted over i
don't know what material
i think the report states that case or
whatever it is and i totally agree
it's going to be urbanization um yes it
would have to have a
car going in the buses they're very very
few
and frequent and regarding a railway
station
actually on virtually every appeal
i think the inspector has drawn
attention to the fact that there might
be a railway station
there's no football it's unlimited and
it's and it's a considerable distance
actually away from the main hub of the
settlement
and also of course it's a special
landscape area though so i think the
office has got it
thank you councillor chandler i have i
have to say i agree i think there's been
plenty of precedent that's uh
been very clear that old thorn is not
sustainable
um as a as an area
so um in unless anybody else wishes to
speak
i would like to propose that we accept
the officer recommendation to refuse
second if i cancel the helm members can
we do that by a cent
agreed thank you
thank you very much members some item
eight any other items of business that
the chairman of the committee decides
are urgent i have
none so members thank you for your
contributions this evening i now draw
the meeting to a close
at 21.08
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion members i forgot
i'm afraid before the beginning of the
meeting to do my air hostess impression
which is could you please leave the
building by the rear exit
members and officers thank you very much
you